vous savez je me méfie peut-être parce
que le temps a passé je me méfie
beaucoup de toutes les modes
donc je ne suis pas très sensible non
plus à ça les modes méthodologique ce
sont des modes méthodologique et je vais
vous donner un exemple je voulais donner
parce que vous n'êtes pas obligés de me
croire mais je vous donne les documents
sur lequel on parle ce document je lui
ai transmis c'est le cochrane library
ils sont spécialisés peut-être 25 ans
pour analyser toutes les publications et
toutes les recommandations d'accord et
comme maintenant les recommandations
depuis qu'il a été développé quelque
chose s'appelle la médecine basée sur
les évidences et de dire écoutez il faut
avoir un essai ou deux essais randomisés
donc là dessus ils ont étudié et eux
c'est les rois de cette analyse là le
ils ont analysé 250 méta analyse des
analyses qui a regroupé plusieurs années
dans plus de 4000 analyse pour regarder
s'il y avait une différence de résultats
et de qualité entre les études
randomisées les études observationnelles
et la conclusion c'est qu'il n'ya pas de
différence
d'accord donc le fait que les études
randomisées soit l'alpha et l'oméga de
la prise en charge thérapeutique c'est
juste par canton recommandations aussi
parce qu'au bout d'un an
moi c'est les choses qui pour moi aller
de soi mais s'il faut que j'explique que
les explique
moi je regardais les recommandations de
sociétés américaines de maladies
infectieuses je vous ai donné la
référence avec quelqu'un qui a fait une
fois cette analyse en disant combien des
recommandations de la société américaine
de maladies infectieuses sont basés sur
au moins une étude randomisée à 18%
donc il ya 82 % des recommandations
thérapeutiques en maladies infectieuses
aux états unis pour lequel il y à 0 et
hull en devises est d'accord donc il
faut être un peu plus paisible avec sa
avant de dire vous savez c'est la règle
et comme ça sinon vous tuer c'est nous
qui savons c'est de l'idéologie c'est
une des raisons sur lesquelles je ne
veux pas discuter de ça ce plan
idéologique je les fais déjà j'avais
fait jeudi 10 h u qui online où j'avais
invité costagliola pour parler des
méthodes nous n'étions pas d'accord
parce que sur le plan idéologique nous
ne sommes pas là